Melonie large diet
did I say diet that comes to nine
dollars and 37 no no no and she's on the
house but she knew this is you tell him
Tony shut the wall son yeah
check the wall son she was the star of
the 2004 games honey I know you've been
stealing from my truck again for that it
was a long time ago no more you thought
anymore about working at the gym Dancing
with the Stars it's not no luck would
have it the fate of American gymnastics
is in her hands Oh Angie I've been like
printing that we would run into each
other maybe we could exchange phone
numbers or something and what needs to
be the strongest for you to be a
champion my body my endurance hmm my
mental Constitution your mind here's the
deal twitchy I'm the pilot or the
copilot dad it's gonna say stories well
well well hope and Gregory she let hope
train Maggie will be throwing your
daughter's career out the window I won
gold and silver and everyone's talking
about your bronze it's men's gymnastics
which come on don't get scrap
flying for weight that smile off your
face are we praying I love that let's
hold hands you off
buzz off Twitter I feel you trying to
get it up
is it true that it taped down your your
breasts told you yet that first date for
galaxy no call from the bark no yes dish
and Dan no Stacy from Quiznos she's no
God stop
shouldn't we be using my Tchaikovsky
piece cooked piece said it was a class
she'd also say that about a full bush
but we all know that's disgusting